what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
the so superior Ironman is like one of
the best stories ever and it's hilarious
because like you guys have been
screaming at me to do superior Ironman
like Rob we need the superior Iron Man's
[Music]
it's pretty funny to me it's pretty
interesting because it really is just a
great story now here's the deal a
superior Iron Man comes out of two
things the first thing is the second
wave of Marvel now and the other one is
axis now we haven't done axis yet and
really the only motivation for me to do
axes was to lead into superior Iron Man
so I'll leave it on you guys I mean
accessive is a pretty cool story it's
interesting up to a point but with axes
it basically dealt with the aftermath of
Avengers vs. x-men remember an Avengers
vs. x-men we basically ended up seeing
Cyclops as really in possession of part
of the Phoenix force killing Charles
Xavier
now what this did is it basically sent
some Professor X and sort of this
no-man's land in the sense that what
ended up happening is that Red Skull
basically took the brain of Charles
Xavier and then rechristened himself as
onslaught he basically had Charles
Xavier civilities of course there were
other things going on like creating
concentration camps things like that but
the idea was that in order for Red Skull
to be defeated there was actually a
spell that was cast by dr. strange of
Scarlet Witch and what this did is that
basically inverted people's moral
compasses so good guys became bad guys
bad guys became good guys in the
instance of Tony Stark his comic book
character basically became Tony Stark
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's essentially what happened now the
funny thing about this is that when the
spell was reversed again basically
meaning that people will return back to
the way that they were supposed to be
Iron Man shielding himself and so the
result was that when everybody went back
to normal
Tony Stark stayed being a jerk now the
reason why Marvel did this is because at
the end of the run of Iron Man that we
had just finished so the whole thing
with like god-killer armor and Arno
Stark the secret brother of Tony Stark
didn't things like that Marvel had about
12 months between the end of that story
the end of that run and the start of
all-new all-different marvel and the
idea was that with Secret Wars Connie
Marlowe was basically winding down
stories that's why you saw things like
the last days of of different characters
last stage of Asgard last days of like
The Punisher different things like that
and so what Marvel did is instead of
just crafting this you know grandiose
story with Tony Stark and last
days different things like that instead
Tom Taylor was brought on board and just
gave us like this short run of Ironman
where he was basically just a jerk and
it's amazing so so with all that
exposition out of the way again what
this does is it actually picks up with
San Francisco now this really just kind
of follows Tony Stark moving from New
York to San Francisco proper and he
actually takes up residence at Alcatraz
but it initially picks up with with
she-hulk facing against some villain
named teen teen abomination which is
kind of a weird scenario but of course
when iron man's head gets knocked off
people start to panic only for us to
find out that it's not actually Tony
Stark himself instead is one of his
autonomous suits we end up finding out
is that he's partying with like a bunch
of super hot chicks back at his place
now of course this leads into Pepper
Potts now one of the things that I want
to talk about here for a second and
we'll cover this a little bit more as we
get into the next video is something
called stark resilient but stark
resilient was the Matt Fraction run of
iron man and we actually hadn't covered
that that was the run of iron man that
took place before the one that we just
did and in truth it's really like the
aftermath to civil war so as basically
Tony Stark as director of shield now the
idea here is that with stark resilient
it was basically iron man trying to
quote-unquote turn over a new leaf
it was Tony Stark back then basically
saying okay I don't necessarily want to
be the weapons manufacturer what I want
to do is I want to start creating
products that could just make life
better for the world so when it comes to
like the Marla Cinematic Universe iron
man when he got to the point in the
first film when he basically created the
Iron Man armor the actual real Iron Man
armor and then told Obadiah Stane he
wanted to drop weapons manufacturing
that's basically that element of mass
fractions run rolled over into the movie
at least I'm pretty sure that fractures
right happened before then but stark
resilient was a new name of that company
so it focused on new forms of technology
different things like that phone
development so on and so forth and all
that served the purpose of just making
the world a better place the issue was
that Tony Stark realizing that pepper
was a person who would always be in
danger and aside moved her away from
Stark Industries and put her in stark
resilience so they basically run two
different companies now the idea here is
that with Pepper Potts basically running
up on him what were introduced to is the
new Iron Man armor the endow sim or mer
now this is probably one of the coolest
suits ever like it's one of the coolest
Iron Man armors ever not only does it
just look amazing but it's an armor that
actually responds to the psychic
control of Tony stork now again that's
not new extremists the extremists suit
did the exact same thing but the whole
idea here is that this is modeled and
predicated on the venom scindia now the
Venom symbiote is basically this simian
that is sentient
it does think for itself that works
alongside the host the idea here is that
with this suit Tony Stark as Iron Man
can basically modify it in a litany of
different ways it basically serves the
purpose of being an extension of himself
and so it just looks really awesome now
there are some perks to it that we
haven't really seen before and we'll
actually see those as this video
progresses but again this is really him
just being a dick what he had basically
done is he had used this extremist 3.00
app in order to give everybody in San
Francisco the ability to be beautiful
now this is where we start coming out of
the whole Arno stark storyline and
that's the biggest issue with superior
Ironman is at the end of our last run we
had talked about the rings of the
Mandarin different things like that are
no Stark the brother of Tony had
basically taken the extremists
technology and then modified it to
essentially become something that can be
used so like heal people it was
basically this like humanitarian
technology what Tony did is he took that
extremist Tech from Arno and then he in
turn modified it just for selfish means
and what he did is he distributed this
app among the entire population of San
Francisco granting them what they
perceived to be the perfect life meaning
they were all beautiful people the
problem with this is that the app only
has a trial period and when the trial
period ends they go back to looking like
their normal selves well this progresses
exactly as we would think it would in
the sense that people just start
freaking out because for them now it's
like an addiction not only that you have
those who see themselves as beautiful
and those who don't have the apnea they
don't have you know a phone to tap into
it or ever the case may be but it's not
activated for them and so the result is
that it's basically creating this social
class the social wart among the various
classes that exist now of course this
also brings it to the equation
daredevil now historically speaking
daredevil has almost always operated out
of New York
but when writer Mark Waid took over with
daredevil volume 3 with issue number 36
or 38 I believe what he did is as part
as the second role on the second phase
of the original Marvel now event he
basically moved Matt Murdock to San
Francisco and that basically saw the new
solution of Nelson and Murdock as a
lawyer team and so it simply just kind
of sitting at Murdoch
along his own way but the idea was that
with Mark Waid it was changing things up
now again patter pots really kind of
panics here and that's the cool thing
because remember in the Ironman
landscape Pepper Potts is consistently
the voice of reason
she's like the responsible parent and
Tony Stark's just the irresponsible
teenager and so with this at race period
ending Ironman is charging people $99 a
day in order to be able to continue
using this app is absolutely crazy it's
like an Apple product so because of this
what we end up finding out is that
somewhere along the line the mind of
Tony Stark was backed up in a digital
form what we actually end up doing here
is taking this segment where we wind all
the way back to like 1972 with Ironman
number 53 and I want to say all the way
up to 1975 with Ironman issue number 72
I'm not gonna swear to that but there
was a villain that was named black llama
and of course we'll talk a little bit
more about this but he was a guy that
was created by a dude named Matt
Friedrich essentially what had happened
is that the mind of Tony Stark
at least when Tony Stark had been
defeated because he was almost
guaranteed death and escaped by the skin
of his teeth his mind was backed up and
so the result is that this is basically
Pepper Potts talking to a earlier
version of Ironman
now of course at the moment we didn't
know this all we knew is that it was
somebody donning the Ironman suit but
because of the actions of Tony Stark and
swindling the people of San Francisco
this leads into a direct conflict
between himself and daredevil because of
the fact that you know Tony Stark is
really just kind of turning a darker
approach here the idea is to basically
start weeding out people that might try
to defy him and so what he does is he
actually gathers the entire city of San
Francisco which is just an insane number
of people and actually says hey look
show up at this location is
such-and-such and you'll all get like a
free sample of the whole extremest tech
now of course this leads it to a direct
conflict with a guy but of course this
again highlights another instance of
what the armors capable of in the sense
that he can basically turn itself
translucent it can make it appear as
though he's not covering his face which
he actually is but this also shows us
the darker lengths of Tony Stark
remembered Tony Stark had always been a
guy who was teetering on the edge and
for years and years and years and years
alcoholism was always a major part of
his character he was always this thing
where it was like if anything was gonna
bring the Empire start crashing down it
would be his addiction to alcohol now of
course this really seemed to culminate
in the demon in a bottle storyline fun
fact it wasn't until the final issue of
the story that it was actually called
demon in a bottle where his alcohol is
almost did cost him his entire company
but coming back from it all it basically
resulted in him kind of moving forward
and trying to be a good guy and so for
the most part well I wouldn't say he was
like a humanitarian he was certainly
falling more in line with what a
traditional hero should be as opposed to
the way he was before which was more
geared towards capitalism and so because
of this this is a stark contrast no pun
intended with how he used to be in the
sense that now he basically tells this
guy look your son literally ran up on a
chick and tried to rob her and so I can
make this go away
the only thing you need to do is go down
there and tell people that you agree
with my ideas my motivations and
extremists take now on the surface it
doesn't seem like a huge thing but it is
because this is basically a superhero
blackmailing a small-time guy just for
the purpose of trying to make sure that
the world believes that what he's doing
is actually right and that's why it's so
enough arias in the aftermath of this
and with daredevil watching all of it
unfold it leads to him kidnapping Tony
Stark now of course this is really
daredevil just trying to interrogate him
as soon as stark wakes up he immediately
recalls us into some armor to himself
and then in turn tells daredevil I'm
giving you a gift and this is one of the
most mind-blowing moments of the story
because when Matt Murdock wakes up what
he ends up finding is that he can see he
has his eyesight back now this was a
huge moment in the story and it's really
one of the biggest moments for Matt
Murdock's character the reason for this
is because his lack of eyesight has been
the defining attribute of who he is as a
person in the comics it was always a
cornerstone of every writer who ever
focused on daredevil how he deals with
the world around him while
simultaneously trying to be a blind
superhero and in fact there were years
and years and years and years when no
one knew he was blind and even now in
the Marvel Universe with the time the
story was written a large bulk of it
don't know that he's blonde and so in
this instance with his blindness being
one of the most defining attributes of
his character considering it's been part
of his life since he was a child it's
been how he's learned to cope with the
world to suddenly have his eyesight back
is this temporary gift now again he's
told by Tony Stark you're not gonna have
it forever it's a temporary thing it's a
very short thing but I want you to
experience this I want you to see what
the world is like and then ask yourself
are you really willing to give that up
now the other half of this is it really
shows us how far gone Tony Stark has
come when he basically says look that
whole thing with axes the whole thing
with the Red Skull so on and so forth
that show
me who by truly an then I've basically
been dumbing myself down and were to
make all of you out there feel like
you're intelligent instead why should I
do that
and so he's run drunk on his own power
his own abilities his own intelligence
so on and so forth and so again this is
a pretty dark fall for his character
because what this does is it leads into
this quote-unquote return of teen
abomination teen abomination basically
breaks out a shield custody and then
when Iron Man shows up he just kind of
whisks him away and says look you know I
will take you under my wing I'll
basically try to help you as best I can
now this comes out of the fact with this
revelation the teen abomination is
actually just a 13 year old kid that's
really all it is he was just blasted
with gamma radiation somewhere along the
line and that was really about it but
with Matt Murdock's character again this
is one of the saddest moments because
switching back to him he goes and he
sees foggy Nelson because he just wants
to see what he looks like with his own
eyes if only ever one time if only ever
for a brief moment for a few seconds he
wants to see what he looks like of
course his eyesight fades away he ends
up going back to seeing things the way
he normally does but this is a huge
situation for Matt Murdock because it's
this very tempting thing okay I give in
like I will I'll take my eyesight I'll
fall in line with a whole you know stark
ideology I'll do whatever it takes in
order to make sure that I could continue
seeing literally sacrifices role as a
superhero in order to go back to being
able to see again and so continuing on
with with Tony Stark this is when we
start to get into this really nefarious
aspect of his character and what's
really going on with the extremis tech
in this instance it's basically this
idea that he has now implemented these
cameras so to speak you know the iron
drones whatever is it he calls them that
are basically parading around the city
of San Francisco and because that's what
they're doing is they're watching
everything everyone does all the time
basically declaring the place to be a
crime free zone as though it's really
Tony Stark setting himself up to be a
dictator becoming a villain he's really
just becoming a bad guy and so in this
moment when Matt Murdock basically makes
his return on Tony Stark and essentially
says I'm not willing to take in my
ability to see in order to fall in line
with what it is that you do I'm not okay
with that in return
stark basically takes him prisoner and
then wipes his mind basically just takes
away Matt Murdock's knowledge of
everything that's happened over the
course of the last day so again this is
a huge moment these are the kind of
things that Tony Starks doing that
wiping people's minds spying on people
all the time it's very dictatorial it's
very bad
yeah and so again it's interesting to
see it happen because it's just such a
change but God man he is a total jerk he
is a total bad guy and so from here what
we end up doing is we actually pick up
with a woman named Katrina and this
falls in with the whole origin to a
degree of teen abomination but it also
falls in with the idea that Tony Stark
has always had this under the surface
it's just now showing itself in this
instance Katrina was basically in a
relationship with happy Hogan
essentially the assistant of Tony Stark
but in this scenario there was a process
that was being undertaken that involved
gamma radiation but the shielding for
the lab was not when it needed to be and
so what they ended up doing was
basically seeking out Tony Stark and
saying we need more money to improve
this and Tony Stark's response was no it
was basically you're not gonna get what
you need that money can be spent better
elsewhere and so when the whole
experiment ended up taking place and it
all went awry things played out exactly
like we thought it would it resulted in
Katrina being blasted with gamma
radiation her son being blasted with
gamma radiation which explains how teen
abomination got his powers but then it
starts to fill things up a little bit
more when we end up learning that in
this instance with everything kind of
going under with the whole project
basically being scuttled by Stark
Industries and Katrina being put out of
work that in the moment where you know
her son asked for something that he
can't get he lashes out he freaks out
and he in turn turns in a teen
abomination destroys the house and kills
his mom and so because of this Tony
Stark is effectively responsible for the
creation of teen abomination and the
death of teen abominations mom this also
explains the whole backstory when it
comes to Tony Stark's mind being backed
up and it's basically him talking about
fighting a villain named black llama but
the idea was that when it runs over the
whole event of him basically facing off
against black llama and then ultimately
having the back of his mind in the
process what we end up learning is that
he essentially forgot everything that
had happened his mind had been wiped
from the time that he arrived back home
until whatever it is it happened the
next day and so what isn't happening is
what he basically sends Tina Bhama
nation off when he says yeah sure but
get things sorted out we'll get you
returning back to normal what he begins
doing is asking the question who wiped a
day out of my mind who made me forget
what it was that happened over the
course of that day and so that's where
the second half of the story picks up
who was it that screwed over Tony Stark
who is it that white that day during his
mind and what was it that happened
during this day of course you know how
do things are not progressing over the
course of superior Iron Man but
without being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come this explain
and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the rod fork
the guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]